because they found out he was covet 19
positive and they yanked him from the
game in that moment which is just kind
of bizarre and it could happen now in
the nfl because as of week six the nfl
started doing game day testing i'm told
they take the sample before the morning
meal
so
as these off-site pcr tests are done
more quickly and the question is how
close are you to the nearest lab
you could in theory
have
the result come back during the game
well what did baseball do they were
moving from the game there's only one
problem
when the dodgers won there he is out
there celebrating
without a mask on yeah he just found out
he's covered 19 positive baseball said
no no you can't go back on the field he
basically said screw you i'm going back
on the field and then he tweet this is
this is poetry this is
this is 2020
in a nutshell
thanks to everyone reaching out i feel
great no symptoms at all just experience
every emotion you can possibly imagine
can't believe i couldn't be out there to
celebrate with my guys are you freaking
kidding me justin turner
we saw you i mean is he going to try the
old eddie murphy it wasn't me routine
we saw you and your distinctive red
beard you were celebrating with your
team
with no mask and he's covered 19
positive he turned the celebration into
a super spreader event chris so you know
the only reason we're talking about this
what we're talking about for two reasons
number one i can't believe it happened
no i can't either
the number two the nfl
now can't say
if there's a guy running around with the
trophy
in february in tampa who somehow slipped
through the cracks as coveted 19 pauses
they can't say well we didn't see that
coming
no they definitely can't you know i mean
first off i mean i i'm sick of this in
our culture right now
like acting like i'm an idiot that i'm
i'm sick of being disrespected that way
to where it's like yeah don't believe
what you saw on tv i'm gonna tweet
something out and now that's the truth
you didn't really see the truth like
what stop playing me like a dummy
whether it's tom brady and what down it
is or this or other things that go on
and you're right it's bruce erin's it's
tom brady had nothing to do it's already
had nothing to do with
the world like yeah you know i'm
powerful and you know a big deal and
just you got to take it for what i say
screw anything you saw in the evidence
there
i'm the like what get out of here like
don't insult my intelligence that's
stupid it makes me not want to root for
you ever again with that kind of crap
all right and then
like i don't know mike how did that
happen with them being in a bubble
and
how did they let that go down did the
rest of the team know that they were
sitting there and he was coveted 19
positive and celebrating with them i
mean i just to me is astounding i fell
asleep in the eighth inning so i didn't
see all of it go down afterwards because
i would have loved to seen the reactions
of guys around them and were they like a
little reluctant to hug them and stuff i
would have loved to have seen that but i
don't know i can't speak to of it right
now i i saw some clips of him hugging
guys in the dugout he had a mask on
and and then uh
there's a photo of him without them and
video of him without the mask and
kissing his wife girlfriend whoever it
is i don't follow baseball enough to
know but i don't i assume she's aware of
the fact that he's covered 19 positive
or maybe accepts the fact that she is
too but that's the thing how does it
infiltrate this bubble and how many
other guys are currently in the
incubation period because they were
around him he's positive he was shedding
virus all day and and see
this is another
sad commentary on where we are right now
people are going to be mad that we're
talking about this chris
people are going to think that we're
we're showing
that we are afraid of the virus that
that we shouldn't be talking about the
talk talking about it is the equivalent
of hiding under your bed yeah get out of
here i'm not afraid of the virus i could
care less i hope i get it what i am
afraid of is getting the virus and then
endangering somebody else okay
so there i'm sick of that crap from
everybody i'm sick of hearing like oh
this will probably all go away after the
election oh oh no it won't it's going on
all over the world it has nothing to do
with just our country or anything like
everybody get over it these stupid
talking points
by the way dave roberts to the left of
yeah uh the player yeah uh
he's a cancer survivor
and there he is with with with no mask
on whatsoever i'll tell you how little i
pay attention to baseball i've already
forgotten the guy's name is it justin
hunter is that inner turner turner
i don't know i don't even heard of the
guy until last night he's a good player
i don't watch baseball i'm all in with
football i no longer care about baseball
and you can be mad at me about that this
is a football show the only reason we're
talking about justin turner is it turner
turner justin turner did something
selfish and stupid and baseball let him
and the lesson to the nfl is you better
be damn sure as you get towards your
postseason games and specifically the
games where there will be major
celebrations like the afc championship
the nfc championship the super bowl you
better be sure
that that no one's getting through the
cracks who shouldn't be getting through
the cracks and also we may be getting to
a point where there could be there could
be a guy
who is yanked from a game a night game
because the results from the morning pcr
test have come back
and i'm asking the nfl what would you do
in that situation did you just let it
all play out or do you reach in and say
you out
that'd be interesting you know i i would
think they'd have to yank them out but i
mean again we saw stefan gilmore have it
and whispering into patrick mahomes ears
and he didn't get it so uh but yeah
that's that's very risky to take that
chance to leave him out there i know
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports